peut-être un simple jouet d'enfant au
pire une arme d'entraînement au tir
en tout cas un pistolet à air comprimé
voilà ce à quoi conclure et les
premières analyses balistiques qui ont
suivi samedi soir le meurtre du petit
toufik oi naissent dans la trop célèbre
cité des 4000 à la courneuve chaleur
bruit violences fin de ramadan racisme
entassement tout a été dit depuis 48
heures sur ce meurtre d'un petit garçon
de 10 ans de part et d'autre les autres
politiques s'en empare sur place des
éléments étrangers la cité ont fait
dégénérer une manifestation de
protestation la nuit dernière
des vitrines ont été brisées et une
librairie tabac en partie brûlé mais ce
soir il faut aller plus loin et essayer
de comprendre avec martine gilson et
rozenn koskas ce qu'est vivre à la
courneuve re les 4000 à la courneuve
entre quinze et vingt mille habitants
personne ne sait très bien
pas ou peu de pelouse pas de centre de
loisirs 500 logements inoccupés 50
irrécupérable
car totalement insalubre
m
non
dans 7 5/10 personnes vide huit enfants
entre 3 et 20 ans deux adultes un seul
salaire très peu de meubles ici on ne
vit pas on survit comme dans toute la
cité
public belge fera rien
s'ils sont toujours au coeur de la cité
comme d'habitude ya rien à faire il ya
pas de voix dire y'a rien le plan
mais pas tourner autour des machines et
si sa tête avant les clients
ça s'empire à soi sinon qu'à l'habitude
et on s'en passe un peu alors non nadia
journée c'est quoi par exemple
aujourd'hui bas comme il ya eu
je sais pas moi aujourd'hui comme il ya
de la victime là le petit et toufik
alors se construit un monde où on n'a
même plus le sourire ni rien alors on
rigole même pu lire jouer marché c'est
difficile derrière ces écrans de béton
crois que pour vivre
nous savons bien tous parce que nous
allons tous besoin une fois un minimum
d'espacé et de bien-être ou en osier pas
nourrir et pour pouvoir grandir
je crois que c'est le fait ici à la
courneuve dans cette cité des 4000 je
crois que c'est le fait aussi de tous
les grands ensembles que dont on parle
ce soit sous la région parisienne où
ailleurs partiellement on parle grand
ensemble
forcément on parle de problèmes humains
bien souvent très dramatique si
dramatique les rapports humains
ici les vices de construction détruites
presque toute intimité
katia ses vices de construction est que
les conversations va se passer d'un
logement à l'autre parent c'est par ces
écarts entre le plancher et les panneaux
ou par les écarts entre les dévoiler des
panneaux les bons je ne vois pas comment
on peut parler de cohabitation la combi
type de cohabitation est vendu beaucoup
plus difficile par l'état du bâti c'est
pas qu'une question de ne plus rallye
technique ou de purs alité sociale c'est
aussi une question toute bête de
transmission des la vie privée de l'un
chez l'autre
le ghetto il existe aussi
architecturalement urbaine monde est
derrière ces murs et ya aucune solution
de continuité entre cet espace est celui
de la vie de celui cet espace est celui
de la banlieue alors qu'il est en pleine
ville donc il faut l'ouvrir à la ville
il faut le faire traverser par des rues
il faut que cet espace puis cette
traversée par des gens qui se rendent à
l'autre de la banlieue qui se vend de la
post la mairie en fait je dis n'importe
quoi afin qu'on puisse aussi s'y
trouvait par hasard parce qu'on s'est
perdue aujourd'hui ici on a presque
oublié le quotidien il y a deux jours
tout sic est mort on ne sait toujours
pas qui l'a tué